[Musique]
un album de jazz plutôt jazz fusion avec
un album instrumental en quartet j'ai
voulu
on va exploiter un petit peu
ce quartet la piano flûte basse batterie
qui est un peu la continuité de mon
premier album kinds of 2015
la première fois que je vais jouer ses
morceaux là donc ça va être spécial en
fait pour moi et ce sera l'occasion un
peu de présenter une nouvelle
composition pour la prod j'oublie que
les gens qui aiment ce genre de musique
là
[Musique]
tu connais
j'ai voulu aller vers plus tôt
les applis quand mes influences du début
c'est-à-dire la jazz fusion et des
groupes mythiques
j'écoutais ça le gospel le jazz quand
j'étais jeune et en fait
voilà j'ai pu j'ai plus de date précise
à cet événement là mais en fait voilà je
m'appelle parce que ce que je ressentais
en fait et de ce que je rêvais aussi
plus tard aux musiciens
[Musique]
les espaces
j c
mais
bah c'est du faux mien
et
découvrir venait
prêté une oreille voilà soyez curieux en
fait voilà données
[Musique]